In a recent interview with Yahoo!
Movies, Thor: Ragnarok writer Eric Pearson
revealed that one planned scene was left on
the cutting room floor—it was a spaghetti
joke, and it was pretty gross.
We can't count the number of times spaghetti
has shown up as a gag in a movie or show.
Sometimes it's sweet, other times it's a little
more disgusting.
But the cut scene in Thor: Ragnarok might
have been the most disgusting of all.
Behind the scenes, the writers called it "the
Noodle Worm Scene,'" which should tell you
how gross it was.
Pearson explained:
"It was an emotional check-in moment with
Bruce Banner and Thor before the finale, with
Banner eating alien food and trying to be
serious.
It [looks like] spaghetti, but then he realizes
the thing he's eating is alive on the end."
Yup, in this case, "noodle worm" was entirely
literal.
"Please, Nick, eat some busghetti."
"I didn't realize you enjoyed eating worms!"
So why was the scene cut?
Pearson went on to say:
"I spent so much time on it, and it just never
made it in.
We thought it was this pivotal character moment,
and it never had a place.
It crushed the momentum."
This scene marks yet another moment clipped
from Thor: Ragnarok, which was originally
going to include a second major Thor villain
and feature a flashback scene of a chubby
Thor and an emo Loki.
Maybe the "noodle worm" will still make an
appearance in a future Thor movie, although
something tells us you'd never look at a plate
of spaghetti the same way again.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!